today we're gonna do the pandas tutorial
hello my name is Richard Kirchner with
the simply learned team that's WWMT
learn comm get certified get ahead
pandas really is a core python module
you need for doing data science and data
processing there's so many other modules
to come off of it there it actually sits
kind of on numpy so if you've already
had our numpy array hopefully you've
already gone through the numpy tutorial
1 & 2 so today we're gonna cover what is
pandas will discuss series will discuss
basic operations on series then we'll
get into a data frame itself basic
operations on the data frame file
related operations on a data frame
visualization and then some practice
examples roll up our sleeves and get
some coding underneath there let's start
with just some real general what is
pandas pandas is a tool for data
processing which helps in data analysis
and provides functions and methods to
efficiently manipulate large data sets
now this is a step down from say using
spark or heard oop in big data so we're
not talking about big data here but we
are talking about pandas and there is
some connections there's like an
interface going on with that so there is
availability but you really should know
your pandas because if you're working in
big data you'll know there's data frames
well pandas is a data frame primarily it
has a couple different pieces we'll look
at here and if you've never worked with
data frames before a data frame is
basically like an Excel spreadsheet you
have rows and columns you can access
your data either by the row or the
column I mean you have an index and
different that kind of set up and we'll
dig more into that as we get deeper into
pandas but think of it it is like a
giant Excel spreadsheet it's optimized
to run a larger data on your computer
and then I said it that it's a data
frame so the data structures in pandas
are series one-dimensional arrays and
then we have data frame two-dimensional
array and it really centers around the
data frame the series just happens to be
part of that data frame and here's a
closer look at a pandas series series is
a one-dimensional array with labels it
can contain any data type including in
strings floats Python objects and more
so it's very diverse if you remember
from numpy we studied they had to be all
uniform not in pandas and pandas we can
do a lot more in pen is actually kind of
sits on numpy so you really need to know
both of those if you haven't done the
numpy tutorials you can see here we have
our index one two three four five and
then our data a b c d and e very
straightforward it's just two columns
and we have a nice index label and a
column label for the data and then a
data frame is a two dimensional data
structure with labels we can use labels
to locate data and you can see here we
had if we go back one we had our index
one two three four five so in each one
of these series they would share the
same index over there the row index so
you have your row index DF dot index and
then you have a column index DF call-ups
and this would look like I said this
would be really familiar if you've done
any work with spreadsheets Excel so it
kind of resembles that this does make it
a lot easier to manipulate data and add
columns delete columns move them around
same thing with the rows so you have a
lot of control over all of this
now we're of course going to do this in
Urdu paterno book you can use any of
your Python editors but I highly suggest
if you have it installed Jupiter and
haven't worked with it it is probably
one of the best ways for easily
displaying a project you're working on I
skip between a lot of different user
interfaces or IDE s
for editing my Python and it's just
simply Jupiter org
jup y ee r dot org and then i always let
mine sit on anaconda anaconda calm and
just real quick we'll open that up for
you oops offline mode don't show me that
again but you can see here that I have
different tools that I can actually
install in my anaconda including the
Jupiter notebook which comes by default
and then I have access to the
environments and again that's anaconda
comm named after the Leary large where
the largest world's largest snakes and
then Jupiter notebook in this case
Jupiter org and when we're in our I'm
gonna go in here to our Jupiter notebook
and we're gonna go ahead and just do new
and a Python three and this will open up
a Python three untitled folder so diving
right in let's go ahead and give
a title panda's tutorial and we'll go up
to sell and we'll change the cell type
to markdown so it isn't execute it as
actual code one of those wonderful tools
when you have Jupiter notebook so you
can do demos with this and let's go
ahead and import pandas and usually
people just call it PD that's become
such a standard in the industry so we'll
go ahead and run that know we have our
pandas has been imported into our
Jupiter notebook and then we can go
ahead and let me do the ctrl + that's
its internet explorer I can enlarge it
very easily so you have a nice pretty
view whoops too big there we go
and whenever you're working with a new
module is good to check your version of
the module in pandas you just used the
in this case PD dot underscore
underscore version underscore underscore
that's actually pretty common in most of
our Python modules there's different
ways to look up the version but that's
one of the more common one and we'll go
ahead and run that we get point to three
point four and if we go to the pandas
site we see zero point two three point
four is the latest release and of course
a reminder that if you're going to
environment you need to install it so
you'll need to do pip install pandas if
you're using the PIP installer will go
close out of that and the first thing we
want to do is we're gonna work with
Ceres a lot of stuff you do in series
you can then do on the whole data set we
need to do what create one we need to
manipulate it take pieces of it so query
query it delete so you can delete
different parts of it so we want to do
all those things with the series and
we'll start with the series and then
almost all the code and in fact all the
code does transfer right into the actual
data table so we go from a series of a
single list of one column and then we'll
take that and we'll transfer that over
to the whole table and we'll start by
creating let's put them there we go
creating a series from list and let's
just call this a are our equals and
we'll do 0 1 2 3 4 if you remember from
our last one we could easily do our
equals
range of 5 which would be 0 to 4 what
we'll do our equals 0 to 4 and we'll
call this s1
and we'll go PvE and Ceres is
capitalized this one always throws me is
which letters do you Capitol Heights on
these modules they're getting more and
more uniform but you got to watch that
with Python and we're just gonna go
ahead and do a RR so we're just gonna
take this Python list and we're going to
turn it into a series and then because
we're in Jupiter we don't have to put
the print statement we can just put s1
and it'll print out this series for us
let's go ahead and run that and take a
look and you'll see we have two rows and
numbers so the first one is the index
now it automatically creates the index
starting with zero unless you tell it to
do differently so we get zero index row
0 0 1 1 2 2 3 3 4 4 and because it's a
series it doesn't need a title for the
column there's only one column so why
title it and this also lets you know
that it's a data type of integer 64 so
we print this out this is our series our
basic series we've just created now
let's do second series PD and we'll use
the same data list and let's go ahead
and do order well give it an order
equals oh let's do it this way let's go
index equals order it helps if we
actually give it an order so we'll do
order equals and let's do 1 2 3 4 5 so
instead of starting with 0 we're gonna
give it an order starting with 1 we're
gonna run that and we'll go ahead and
print it out down here s 2 and we'll see
that we now have an index of 1 2 3 4 5
and that represents 0 1 2 3 4 in the
series and we're still data type integer
64 and very common as you're missing
with numpy arrays is we can import our
numpy as in p remember that from our
numpy tutorials we can go ahead and
create a numpy out of random with the
random numbers of 5 and let's just see
what that end looks like so we can see
what it looks like so we have some nice
random float values here 2.3 3 so on and
this from our last tutorial
the numpy tutorial 1 and 2 and instead
of calling it order let's call it index
and we're going
Center index equal to a B C D and E well
I want to show you that the index
doesn't have to be an integer so it can
be something very different here and
then let's go ahead and create our I'll
just use s2 again and here's our NP for
numpy series capital s and n is er and P
for numpy PD for pandas there we go
switching my anachronism so we have PD
that series of N and we will do our
index equals our index we just created
and then let's go ahead and see what
that looks like s2 is a print it let's
run that and we can see here we have a
nice series going on ABCD and E for our
indexes so instead of it being 0 1 2 3
or 4 we can make this index whatever we
want and you see the numbers here going
down that we randomly generated from the
number array so we use numpy to create
our pandas series right here and so
continuing on with creating our series
just want to use so often we create a
series from a dictionary so we have our
dictionary in this case we went ahead
and did a of 1b is to see a 3 d 4 EF 5
so each one of those is a key and then a
value and then we're gonna use oh let's
use s3 equals PD for pandas series and
then we want to go ahead and just do D
in here print out s3 here and let's go
ahead and run this and you can see we
got a is 1 B is 2 C is 3 D is 4 e is 5
and is still of integer 64 because the
actual data is 1 2 3 4 5 and it's all
integers 64 type 64 and the last thing
we want to do in the creating section of
our series is to go ahead and modify the
index so we're going to start modifying
all this data so let's start with
modifying the index of the series and if
you remember let's do a print this time
s 1 I'll go ahead and run this and the
reason I did print is because it only
prints out the last variable so if I put
s 1 up here and we're gonna do another
variable back down lower it won't print
the first one just the last one and
we're going to go ahead and take s 1 the
index
just gonna set it equal to a new index
and obviously the number of objects in
our index has to equal the number of
objects in our data and then because
it's the last variable we can go ahead
and just do an s1 and let's run that and
you can see how we went from 0 to 0 0 1
2 3 4 s our index we've now alternate to
a B C D and E so this would be much more
readable or might be representational of
a larger database you're working with so
cool tools we've covered creating
database based on my basic array Python
array we've showed you how to do reset
the index then we showed you how to do
use a numpy array so you can put a
number array in there it's all the same
you know PD dot series numpy array and
then we can set the index on there and
the same thing with the dictionary so
it's very versatile how it pulls in data
and you can pull in data from different
sources and different setups and create
a new series very easily in the pandas
and then we looked on changing your
index so now we have a new index on here
and then we want to go ahead and do some
selection let's do some basic slicing
the most common thing you'll probably do
on here we'll just do s1 this notation
should start to look really familiar
again this is going to put an output so
I'd usually it doesn't change s1 this
just selects it so we might do a equals
s1 and then print a and you'll see that
it just looks at the first three zero
one two we can do the same thing by not
having the a in there I'll go ahead and
take that out it's just a reminder that
it's not actually changing s1
it's just viewing s1 so simple slicing
on here and we can likewise do an append
oops before we do a pen let's just do a
quick kind of fun one we'll do two minus
one and you'll see it covers everything
but the e of course you can do minus two
on this side so one another way to
select it is to go how far from the end
and likewise we can do a two here CDE to
the end so it starts at the second one
and another way we can do this is we can
do a minus two over here and that looks
at just the last two in the slice so you
can see how easy it is to slice the data
and of course
there's no reason to do this but you
could select all of them if you went to
view all of them on there oops 32
there's not 32 so it's just going to
show the first three there we go
and then we can also app int so I can
take and let's create another series and
append one to it and if you remember we
had s3 there's our s3 and we have our s1
I'm going to do s1 and let's go ahead
and do let's call it s 4 equals s1 app
in s3 so we're just going to combine
those two into S 4 and if we go ahead
and print s4 on here you'll now see that
we have ABCDE ABCDE 0 1 2 3 4 1 2 3 4 5
because we started the data at 1 so very
easy to compendious to the next and if
we're going to append one series to the
next we need to go ahead and drop or
delete one and drop is a key word for
that and let's just do II our index E
and so if I run this you'll see that
it'll print it out and ABCD there's no E
and remember all these changes if I type
in s4 again you'll see that s4 still has
ay in it so this change does not affect
the series unless you tell it to so I'd
have to do like XS 4 equals s4 drop e
and there's another way to do that which
we'll show you later on we just cut this
one out there we go alright so we've
covered all kinds of cool tools here we
have appending we have slicing we did
all the creating stuff earlier you can
see here on the setup how easy it is to
manipulate the series so next what we
want to get into is we want to get into
operations that happened on the series
so let me go ahead and change this cell
to mark down there we go and run that so
series operations what can we do with
the series and let's start by creating a
couple arrays will call it array 1 and
we'll do 0 through 7 and arrayed to 6
through 6 7 8 9 5 through the 5 on the
end let's go ahead and run those so
those load up into Jupiter
we'll do this little backwards we're
gonna do s 5 equals a panda series of
array 2 so I'm doing this in Reverse and
then when we do s 5 you'll see that we
have 0 2 4 and automatically assign the
index 6 7 8 9 5 or our series and let's
go ahead and do the same and we'll call
this s 6 and we'll set this equal to PD
series for our first array and if we do
an S 6 down here to print it out we'll
see something similar I got 0 through 6
0 1 2 3 4 5 7 for the data so those are
two series we've just created series 6 5
& 6 and one of the first things we can
do is we can add one series to the next
so I can do s 5 dot add s 6 and let's
see what that generates in just a quick
thing if you never use pandas what do
you think is gonna happen with the fact
that this only has 5 different values in
it and this one has 7 values so let's
see what that does and we end up with 6
8 10 12 9 and it goes oh I can't add
this there's nothing there so it gives
us a no return I'm very different than
the number that would have given you an
error this is dead tells you there's no
value here because we couldn't generate
one so we can easily add s5 dot add s 6
and likewise we can do s 5 . sub 4
subtract s 6 and we'll run that and on
the add the subtract and you guessed it
we're going to do multiply and divide
next again you can see there's no values
where it can't subtract the 2x there's
no values there to subtract we can also
do s 5 multiply mu well they're all
three letters on these that's one of the
ways to remember how they figured out
the code for this so remember these are
all three letters mul will go and run
this and you can you can see how they're
multiplied together and then we can also
do the S 5 div 3 letters again s 6 and
run that and you'll see here this goes
to infinity because we have 0 in the
wrong position so it actually gives you
a whole different answer here that's
important to notice and then in the null
values because there's no
it can't actually produce an answer off
of an old off of missing data and since
we're in data science
let's do s6 median so let's look at the
median data which is simply median sorry
for those we're following the three
letters because median is not three
letters and you can see an S six is 3.0
and let's do a print here and we'll do
median or average S six and let's print
max comma s6 and just like median
there's max value and if we're gonna
have a max value we should also have a
minimum value so let's pop in minimum
we'll go ahead and run this and you're
starting to see something that would be
generated like say NR where you're
starting to get your different
statistics we have a median value of
three max value of seven and a minimum
value of zero and what it does when it
hits these null values if there is no
values in there because we could still
do that we could actually you know what
let's go up here and do
let's pick this one we multiplied let's
go s 7 equals I'll go to print the s 7
just so I keep it nice and uniform so I
still have my s 7 down there and run it
and then I want to take the s7 s7 now
has no values and an infinity value and
let's see what happens this is gonna be
interesting so I was here just with
infinity and we end up with a median of
6 maximum of 27 and minimum of 0 which
is correct
it drops those values so when he gets to
there and it doesn't know what to do
with them it just drops those values and
then it computes it on the remaining
data on there so that's important to
know when you're making these
computations you're looking at min and
Max and median you're not going to know
that there's no values unless you double
check your data for the null values it's
a very important thing to note on there
so just a real quick review on there
we've done our creditor PD series and
we've gone ahead and an addition
subtraction multiplication division all
those are three letters so sub men div
ad and then we looked at median maximum
and minimum so we're going to go ahead
and jump into the next big topic which
is to create a data frame so now we're
going to go from series and we're going
to create a number of series and bundle
them together to make a data frame
there we go cell type worked out so we
have a nice title on there it's always
good to have a good title all right so
our first data frame will jump in with
some stuff that looks a little
complicated we'll break it down first
I'm gonna create some dates and you know
what let's just go ahead and do this I
want you to see what that looks like
what I'm creating here I've created a
series of dates PD date range and we're
gonna use these for the index okay so
when you look at this you'll see that
it's just basically it comes out kind of
like a basic Python list or numpy array
however you want to look at it with our
different dates going down and we've
generated six of them and it's going to
have whatever time it is right now on
your on the thing for the date for the
time that's that time stamp right there
and then you'll see we have eleven
nineteen two thousand eight eleven
twenty eleven nineteen and looking into
the future there so that's all this is
is generating a series of dates that
we're gonna use as our index and this is
a panda's command so we have a date
range which is nice that's one of the
tools hidden in there and the pandas
that you can use and next we're gonna
use numpy to go ahead and generate some
random numbers this case will do the NPD
random dot random in six comma four you
can look at this as rows and columns as
we move it into the pandas and of course
you could reshape this if you had those
backwards on your data but we want the
six or match the rows and we have six
periods so our indexes should match
along with the rows on there and then
you know before we do the next one let's
go ahead and just print out our numpy
erase you can see what that looks like
here we have it one two three four by
one two three four five six four by six
that's just a nice little setup on there
and since working with data frames can
be very visual let's give our columns we
have four columns and we're going to
give them names a b c and d so now we
have columns on there also and then
let's put this all together in a data
frame and we can actually you know what
let's do this they did it with
everything else let's go ahead and do
columns and you can see there's our
columns on there and we'll go ahead and
do DF 1 equals pandas dot data frame
and note that the D and the F are
capitalized series it was just the s and
I always highlight this because you
don't know how many times these things
get retyped when you forget what's
capitalized on there it's a minor thing
you'll pick it up right away if you do a
lot of it and the first thing we want to
do is we want to go ahead and take our
numpy array so so we're gonna create our
data frame off of it's a numpy array and
then we want our index equal to our
dates so there's our index in there and
then we also have columns equals columns
and then finally let's see what that
looks like
remember we had all that different data
that just looked like a jumble of data
we have our column names and everything
else or numpy array kind of just a
jumbled array over there 4x6 you could
sort of read it but look how nice this
looks I mean this is you come into a
board meeting you're working with your
shareholders this is pretty readable
this is you know this is our date this
is our ABCD whatever it is maybe it's
one of these dates has your leads
closures lost leads total dollar made
you know whatever it is if it's in a
business maybe its measurements on some
scientific equipment wither searching
material you know where this is like
higher the temperature low of the day
humidity of the date whatever it is so
you can see that we can really create a
nice clear chart and it looks just like
a spreadsheet you know we have our rows
and we have our columns and we have our
data in there now this one I use all the
time if we're gonna create we can create
it like you saw here with our numpy
array very easy to do that in reshape it
you can also create it with a dictionary
array so here we have some data let me
just go down a notch so you can see all
the data on there we have an animal in
this case Cat Cat snake dog dog cat
snake cat dog we have the age so we have
an array of ages we have the number of
visits and the priority was it a high
priority yes/no and then we're gonna
take that we're gonna create some labels
we have abcdefgh I and what I want you
to notice on this is we have a title
animal and then we have basically a
Python list and these lists they don't
necessarily have to be equal because we
can have non data you know NPN numpy
array null value but we want
and create labels are equal to the
number in the list so a the first cat be
the second cat see the snake be the dog
and so on so we'll go ahead and create
our labels which we're going to use as
an index and we'll call this D F let's
do it this way we'll call this D f2
equals P D for panda's data frame and
then we have our data just like we did
before and then we have our index equals
labels and if we're gonna go from there
let's go ahead and print it out so we
can see what that looks like
d f2 let's just go ahead and run that
another again you have a nice very clean
chart to look at we've gotten from this
mess of data here to what looks like a
very organized spreadsheet very visual
and easy to read animal age visits
priority and then a through J cats and
all the different animals so on and so
on and then when you do programming a
lot of times it's important to know what
the data types are so we can simply do D
F to D types and if we run that we can
see that our animal is an object because
it's just a string but it comes in as an
object age is a float 64 integer 64 and
then priority again is just an object
and exploring this this one's very
popular let's go D F to a head and if we
print that out the D of 2 head returns
the first 5 and we can change this you
don't have to do 5 you might want to
just look at the top 1 2 maybe you want
to look at let's see well let's do 6 so
maybe we'll look at just the top 6 in
the database and your data frame and you
can actually this creates another data
frame so I could have DF 3 equal to DF 2
and this now takes the DF 2 and just the
first 6 values so if we do DF 3 run get
the same answer
if we do it the head of the data we can
also do the tail it's the same thing d/f
tail you can look at the last we'll just
do the tail which by default does 5 the
last 5 and of course you can just look
at the last three of those real quick
just to see what's at the end of the
data and this is the TEL I love doing
the tail of one because I'll have like
the index or something like that and it
will just show me the last whatever the
last entry was looking at stock values
and I might want to look at just the
last five days of the stock values I can
do that with the data frame tail and
some other key things to look up are the
index so we can do DF to index you know
I want you to notice that this isn't a
call function so if I put the brackets
on the end it'll give me an error
because index just not callable it's
just an object in there so we do do you
have to dot index
there's also columns so we can go ahead
and let's do it let's print this
remember the first one it's not going to
show unless I print it and then D of two
columns so now we can see we have our
indexes and we have our columns listed
here DF two columns
animal age visits priority and tells you
what kind of object it is or what kind
of data type it is and they're both
object and then finally DF 2 dot values
and again there's no brackets on the end
of DF 2 dot values because this is an
actual object it's not a culpable
function so we'll go ahead and run that
and it creates just displays a nice
array a very easy way to convert this
back to a numpy array basically so
before I go into the next section let's
just take a quick look at what we
covered so far with the data frame we
came up here we created our data frame
we did it from a numpy array first
setting the columns and the index the
index is setting it up is the same as
when we set up the series so that should
look very familiar
so is the whole format the number array
the index dates and the columns columns
and remember in our numpy array we're
looking at row comma column so six rows
four columns is how that reads in the
data frame
and we went ahead and also did that from
a dictionary in this case animal was the
column name with all the date data
underneath that column and then age with
that data visits that data priority of
that data and then of course we added
our labels in there for our index so
there's no difference in there but it
automatically pulled the column names
important to know when you're dealing
with the data frame and importing a data
frame this way and then we did looking
up d-type we looked at head and tail
looking at your data really quick we
also did index and columns and values
and note these don't have the brackets
on the end so the next thing we want to
do is go ahead since we're dealing with
data science is we want to go and
describe the data so we have DF 2 dot
describe to do that and we're going to
manipulate it in just a minute but let's
just see what this generates and you can
see right here we have age and visits so
looking at our data from up above we
just go all the way up here animal age
visits priority and it does a nice job
generating your age versus visits which
has all the data in your account your
means your standard deviation your
minimum value 25% or in this group 50%
75 and your maximum value so this will
look familiar as a data science set up
with your describe for a quick look at
your data frame data so let's start
manipulating this data frame moving
stuff around and we'll start with
transposing and it is simply capital T
for transpose and when we run that it
flips the columns and the indexes so now
the indexes are all column names and the
columns are all indexes animal age
visits priority so if we had come in
here with our data shaped wrong up above
where we had a four by six we can
quickly just swap it if we head it
backwards not a big deal
and we can also sort our data something
that you can't do which is more
difficult to do with a lot of other
packages and the data frame is really
easy to do take our data frame D of two
or we're gonna sort underscore values by
equals age and so when we run this
you'll see the default is ascending so
we have point five to two point
I have three and everything else is
organized so if you look at your indexes
they've been moved around because each
and it moves a whole row not just the
one piece of data is not being sorted so
a very quick way to sort by H or a
different data in the data frame and in
addition to sorting it we can also slice
the data frame so I could do D of two
and this should look familiar from
earlier we'll just do one two three so
we're going to pull out whoops it does
help if I use a DF instead of just D and
we kind of pull up just between 1 and 3
so we have not 0 which is a we have B
which is 2 or B which is 1 and C which
is 2 so 1 2 and then it does not include
3 which is the standard in Python and we
can even do something like this we can
combine them which is always fun because
remember this returns a data frame so if
I take DF to dot sort values and we'll
do by equals age this is just kind of
fun and then I'm gonna slice it there we
go double-check my typing and run it and
now you should see FA because FA are now
one and two one there you can very
quickly create a whole string on here
which narrows it you know that you can
sort it then slice it and do all kinds
of fun things with your data frame let's
go back to the original one run there we
go
and if we can slice it by row we can
also query the data frame so we can do
DF 2 and this is a little different
because I'm going to create an array
within an array and in this case we're
gonna look at oh let's do age comma
visits so look at the different format
in here we have 1 2 3 once we've done
this by slicing by an integer value and
then on here I've done DF to age comma
visits in an array and when I run this
you can see that we get just these two
columns on here we get age and visits so
it's a quick way to select just two
columns or select number of columns are
working with and if you stop there we
did the slicing almost identical to
slice is I location which uses the
integer location
1 comma 3 there's a push in pandas to
move to this particular setup instead of
doing just a regular slice and that's
because this can be confusing when we
slice 1 2 3 and then we select age and
visits so there is a push to go ahead
and move to an eye location which does
the same thing you can see here BC
that's the same as up above there's also
a copy command so we can do DF 3 equals
DF true copy we're just gonna create a
straight copy of it and of course if we
do DF 3 it'll be the same as a DF 2 on
there so DF 3 equals DF to copy and then
let's do DF 3 dot is null so we're
looking for null values and this will
return a nice map and you'll see that
everything is false except when you go
up here under the cat or H they had an
OL there and so if we go to have a
couple up here also underneath of that's
your the dog okay there's a bunch of
nulls in here there's d up here so it's
like a d down here and you'll see false
true there it is there's our null value
so we can create a quick chart of null
values you can use this to do other
things we can leverage that null value
to maybe take an average or something
and fill those null spaces with data and
we can also modify the location so
here's our DF 3
location and notice this is location not
eye location our location has eye for
integer location uses the in this case
the variables on the left and what we
can do on here we're going to set this
equal to 1/5 and that's some I'll pick a
spot let's go back up here where we had
let's do F a just looking at oh here we
go let's do F and age and up here F is
set to age of 2.0 and we find out that
that incorrect data so we go ahead and
switch the DF 3 equal and then we're
going to print out our DF 3 and if we go
to F and age it is now 1.5 so we're just
changing the value in the DF 3 and this
is changing the actual data frame
remember a lot of our stuff we do a
slice
and like it returns another data frame
this changes the actual data frame and
that value in the data frame so we've
covered location and eye location is
null making a copy here's our eye
location which is equivalent of a slice
and also selecting columns so now we
want to dive just take a little detour
here and let's look at TD F 3 means and
this is kind of nice because you can do
this you can either do this by as you
can select a single column here by the
way you can just add the column
selection right here like we did before
so we could have age look up the mean
that just creates a series if I run that
there's our age but if I take that out
instead of selecting it we can do the
whole set up and it has age and visits
so why doesn't it have priority or
animal well those are not integers so
it's really hard they're not numerical
values so what is the average I guess
you can do a histogram which probably
we'll look at that later on but the only
two things we can really look at is age
and visits and we have the average or
the mean on the age is three point three
seven five and the mean on visits is one
point nine and let's do df3
visits we'll go ahead and steal the
visits again and you remember all those
different functions we looked at for a
series well we can do those here we can
do the sum so if we run that we will see
that these sum up to nineteen could also
look at minimum if you remember that
from before the minimum is one max so
all that functionality is here I'll just
go back to summing it up and adding it
all together
so real quick we've shown you how to
take the series operations and put them
into the data frame and then we can
actually this is interesting one we can
just do df3 sum run and you'll see the
different summations on there it just
combines them I like the way it just
combines the strings on there for
priority and animal we've looked at is
nope
we've also looked at copying along with
the different slices which we talked
about earlier so let's talk about
strings let's dive into the string setup
on there and let's go ahead and create a
string series string equals PD
series we just put it right in there we
have a CDA a BAC a popped in a null
value cow an owl I don't know why they
picked Cal and owl in the background
someone must like those animals and of
course we can just do string if we run
that you'll see leave the are out we'll
get an error but if we put it in there
you'll see that we have a simple series
0 a 1 C 2 D and it automatically indexes
it 0 to 8 and then we can go string dot
lower so we're talking about our data
frame in this case or a data series
string in this case we're use the string
function STR and we're going to make it
lower and if we go in with the brackets
on there and you'll see that we've gone
from capital a capital C so on to ABC
and baka CB a cow al they were all
lowercase already and of course if you
want to go lower you can also do upper
and we'll go ahead and run that and you
can see we now have a CD AAA bucket
everything's capitalized except for the
null value which is still null
alright so we looked at a few basic
string you can see that string functions
up or lower we're gonna jump into a very
important topic I'm even gonna give it
its own header on here because it's such
an important topic what do you do with
missing values panda has some great
tools for that so we'll dive into those
we'll call will work with D f4 and if
you remember the DF copy from above
we're just gonna make a copy of DF 3 and
let's just take a quick look at the data
we're working with oops DF 3 forgot the
3 on there there we go so here we have
our cat snakes and dogs hopefully not
all in the same container because that
would be just probably mean to all of
them so if we made a copy we're gonna be
working with DF 4 and the reason we made
a copy is we want to go ahead and fill
the data and we just simply do fill in a
and then we're gonna give it the value
we want to put in there we'll give it
the value 4 so I can run in here and
you'll see now that DF 4 now has where
the n/a was it's filled with the value
of 4 same thing down here a lot of times
we'll compute the mean first so I might
do a mean age equals D
four and then we want to go ahead and do
age and mean and then I'll do something
like this D F four I only want to select
the age and I want to fill that with the
mean age I run in there and you'll see
that our dear for age now has the means
in there just a quick way of showing you
how you can combine these let me go back
to our original one there we go and run
that and keeping with good practices DF
v equals DF 3 dot copy little printer DF
5 which should be the original one and
then on the DF 5 we can now drop our
missing data and I simply drop in a and
we're going to use how equals any so I'm
going to drop any row that has missing
data in it and you'll see we had D here
with missing data and H and then let's
go ahead and see what DF 5 looks like
when we do that there we go
and there it is DS gone and so is H so
we've create a new data frame off of
this missing those values now if you
have a lot of data
dropping values is a good way to take
care of it cuz you don't miss some data
if you have not a whole lot of data
you're working with like the iris data
set or something like that or something
small you want to start trying to find a
way to fill that data in so you don't
lose your computational power of the
data you got so just a quick look at
processing null values or missing values
you can fill them usually with the means
some people use media or the mode
there's different ways you can fill it
one way is means and we can also just
drop those rows so those are the two
main things we do with missing data here
we go
we're gonna cover next this is I so love
data frames for this file operations it
saved me so much time because they have
so many different tools for bringing
data in and saving data so we're looking
at the data frame file operations it's
really streamlined I don't know how many
times they'll go on to different data
down
and they'll have panda download standard
on there just because it's so widely
used so let's start with the most common
file is a CSV so we have DF 3 - CSV or
animal and let me just show you the
folders going in - right now I have some
untitled a few things in here but
nothing labeled animal so we go ahead
and run this and this is now saved the
animal to my hard drive and you can now
see the animal folder up here and if I
let's do edit with a notepad
let's open up with just a regular
notepad there we go or WordPad if I open
that up you can see it's comma separated
our titles they don't have an index on
the categories on the top and the index
comma then all the different data is
separated by commas standard CSV file on
there and if we're gonna send it to CSV
and notice a format is dot to underscore
CSV and it's just the name of the file
we're sending it to you can also put the
complete path by default it's going to
go whatever the active directory this
program is running on that's why those
other folders were in there so we have
our D f3 to CSV and then if we're gonna
put it in there we want to also get it
back out and we'll call this one DF
underscore animal equals PD read
underscore CSV I always have to remember
is to underscore CSV and read underscore
CSV I always want to do with like a
capital in there and not the underscore
we're going in here again it's the
active directory so if I now do print
out my DF animal and let's just do the
head really look at the first three
lines so if I go ahead and run this
we'll see the first three lines and they
should match up here where we saved to
our CSV so very easy to save and import
from our CSV files on here and it turns
out DF 3 also has a to excel they
actually have a lot of different formats
but you know old-school Excel is real
popular for so long still is we can go
ahead and save it as animal dot xlsx
we're gonna call the sheet named sheet
one and then I can also do DF we'll call
it animal to animal two and this one's
gonna come from and the same
that on here there we go so we still
have our animal xlsx the sheet one
that's where it's coming from
index columns equals none so we're not
going to we're going to suppress the
indexing on the columns any values it'll
just assign it zero one up on your
indexes so if it says in those columns
equals none that's what it does and then
we've added null values because no
values in here and we want to just make
sure that they're marked as in a and
we'll go ahead and just print out the
animal animal two there we go and let's
run that let's make this let's just do
the whole thing so we'll go ahead and
run that and it probably doesn't help
that a completely forgot the read so
animal two equals PT read Excel there we
go Excel so now we go ahead and run it
and what we expect is happening here we
have the same data frame on here and if
I flick back to my folder you can now
see that we have the animal one of these
is in Excel and one of these is a CSV on
here and so there's our two file types
on there and they have other formats
these are just the two most common ones
used and I don't know how many times
I've had stuff from Excel I need to pull
out if you've ever played with Excel
it's a nightmare in the back end because
of the way they do the indexing so this
just makes it quick and easy to pull in
an Excel spreadsheet so we looked at two
different ways to bring data in and save
it to files we've looked at all kinds of
different ways of manipulating our data
set and slicing it and creating it for
our data frame let's get in there well
your visualisation always a big thing at
the end because one it lets you check to
see what you did make sure it looks
right and then also if you're going to
show somebody else it makes it very
clear what's going on if they see
something visual so this is where a
really important part of data science is
so let's go ahead and bring in our tools
we're gonna do import numpy as NP we
want to make sure we have our amber sine
mat plot library in line this just lets
Jupiter know that we're gonna print it
on this page if you're using a different
IDE you don't really necessarily need
that but this does help it displays
correctly in Jupiter notebook and if you
remember for earlier we could create a
ts we're gonna create a pandas which are
cute cuddly creatures versus a panda
short for pandemonium no so we have T s
equals PD series and we're just gonna
create a random setup of 50 we'll do an
index we'll set it equal to the pandas
date range today periods equals 50 so
the 50 should match you know I want you
to notice something here I did not
import the mat plot library why because
it's already in there pandas already has
its built-in connection and interface
with mat plot library so you don't have
to import it and will go ahead and do T
s equals T s dot cumulative sum we're
gonna do the cumulative sum so a little
reformatting there and we'll go ahead
and plot it and let's take a look at
what that looks like
so we have a nice graph here we have the
dates on the bottom we set this up so we
have a nice range between in this case
minus 4 to looks like about 2 maybe or 1
minus 4 and 1 so what we've done here we
plotted a basic series just a single row
of data when we've said it Dex is on
there but we can also do the whole data
frame on there and let's see what that
looks like so first let's go ahead and
create the data frame we have here
random number so we're gonna do 50 by 4
and then we'll go ahead and create
columns a b x and y just because we can
index is the TS index on there so we're
gonna use the same index as before just
to keep it nice and uniform we've
already generated the dates to go with
it and then we can do just like we did
with the series we can also do with the
data frame DF equals DF cumulative sup
so we're going to sum the whole data
frame and then we'll do simply DF plot
and this puts that in and let's go ahead
and run this and look how easy and quick
that was to generate a nice graph with
all the different data on there so we
have our shared index we have the shared
columns and then we have the different
data from each one that we can easily
look at and compare so very quick way of
displaying data you can imagine if you
were working in oh I think I mentioned
stock earlier because I've been doing
some analysis of stock lately so you'd
have your date down here and then you'd
have stock a stock B
stocke XY whatever it is and you can put
them all on one chart and see how they
what they look like next to each other
and this isn't too far huh from what
some of those graphs looks like and this
is just randomly generated so stuck has
a lot of randomness in it which is one
of the reasons I actually play with it
for doing some of my models on for
testing them out now there are a lot of
features in pandas so we're gonna show
you one more thing on here there's some
of the things like I didn't go too deep
we looked at the top two for importing
data from a CSV and from an Excel
spreadsheet showed you how to quickly
plot the data there's more settings in
there you can do we're gonna do one more
thing down here and this is kind of a
fun one change us to markdown and run
that so how would you remove repeated
data using pandas and this is where you
have a data set that comes in and maybe
it's a feeding from one location and
instead of noting that it's repeated the
date like well let's go back to stocks
that's a good visual we have the stocks
from the 23rd and it has another row and
it's the same row it's importing the
23rd again and again so now you have
that data repeated three times and you
need to go back and figure out how to
get rid of it how do you track that down
so let's start by creating a quick
database our data frame not a database I
keep saying databases and data frame and
will this make this data frame has using
our dictionary going in this data frame
only has one data series in it which is
fine so if we do DF to print it out
you'll see a 1 to 2 2 to 4 5 4 5 6 7 and
so on and so how would you remove that
well there is a neat feature in data
frames called shift along with another
feature that lets us select just certain
information and we'll go with the
location function but that in brackets
remember that from above location and
then in the location let me just spread
this out a little bit so it's real easy
to read in fact I'm gonna go upscale on
that since we're doing some a little bit
more complicated here what you can see
on this on the location is I have d f8
shift
so this is going to shift up one by
default you can actually change this to
two or three you can even do a minus one
and it shifts the other way but it's
going to shift up by one by default
that's going to say if that does not
equal DF of a then we want that if you
look down here we had 1 2 2 2 2 2 when
we run this logic on here and we do the
shift it now gets rid of all the
duplicates so we went from 1 to 2 2 to 4
4 5 whenever it was here it is 1 2 2 2 4
4 4 5 5 5 6 6 6 2 1 2 4 5 6 7 8 and
you'll see on the index it just deletes
them out of there so the index stays the
same obviously you don't want the dates
to change if you're working with an
index dated set up so it just deletes
those duplicates out of there this is
just a quick way to introduce you to one
the fact that you can add logic gates
into here and to the I location allows
you to use shift so there's a shift
function and then the aiya location
selects that based on true or false Wow
so we've actually covered a lot today in
pandas we've really covered into the
basics of selecting your different
series out of your column out of your
data frame how to index rose how to
slice how to plot hopefully you'll take
this beyond that and start combining
these different things and you can
create long strings and really explore
your data and generate some nice graphs
if you're in Jupiter notebook it's a
great demo to show others and I didn't
know this about Jupiter notebook
you can do this in Jupiter notebook and
then you can download and I always I
never really looked too closely at all
the downloads but you download it as an
HTML and post it to your blog so it's
got a neat feature in there but any of
this is really powerful tool all of this
is really powerful tools for doing your
data science which brings us a close for
today which I hope you enjoyed learning
about pandas and not the cute cuddly
ones that live in China but the pandas
in the Python setup I want to thank you
for joining us today for more
information visit www.fema.gov
on the website again my name is Richard
Kirchner with the simply learned team
thank you for joining us today get
certified get ahead
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos de nerd up and get certified
click here